[Music]
okay I think we're live now for real
this time right Jonah yes sir okay happy
Tuesday everybody today's Tuesday so
must be about typography and we ran out
week four where we four into our seven
week course here and we're giving
feedback in case you're joining us
welcome everybody we have 30 live and
willing in able-bodied people
participating with us and returning once
again miss Milkha Brooke hi how are you
doing today I'm doing great thank you so
much for having me back I'm excited for
this week's class are you wearing a new
headset or is that the same last week it
is the same how does the sounds work the
sound is working perfectly okay good
yeah okay so let's get into it I'm gonna
share my screen here I think Jonah I'll
be on my screen yes sir okay so in case
you guys don't know what the heck we're
doing today and hopefully we're
broadcasting in HD resolutions like only
are 800 broadcast but maybe today we'll
get it right is so we don't the reupload
so week for this is as part of the
typography course for people are
wondering how they can participate in
this you just enroll in the class and
then you submit your work and if you're
just starting out or if you've done the
class before you're also invited welcome
to join us in our conversation today
okay anyways one of the things that I
want to remind everybody about when
you're designing this on your own
because truth be told you really do need
a teacher a mentor somebody to help you
out with this stuff but we all can't get
it it's very pricey to get one-on-one
coaching we'll talk a little bit more
about that later but if you're working
on this on your own you have to start to
have a set of rules or guides so that
you can critique your own work the idea
is that the transference to the
transference of knowledge from
instructor to student happens in
outlining something like this so I broke
it down in five points what are we
looking at what's the focal point
what are you as the creator telling me
the audience the viewer the reader to
look at first and that's achieved
through scale and contrast mostly just
contrast
contrast can come in black and white big
and small bold and light heavy or
scattered like heaviest in terms of
concentrated so Milkha has her rules
which is like large medium and small
what kind of shapes are you creating and
how do they play off each other next
part is order like how are the
components that you put together on the
page how is it ordered is it sequence
correctly what is the relationship
between all the components on the page
you have to pay careful attention to
this part number three is is there an
element a surprise because we've seen
layouts that are really following all
the rules but they're a little bit on
the boring side yes they're clean
they're aligning to a grid there's good
hierarchy but you have to create
something for us the viewer the audience
to get pulled into we've seen thousands
if not hundreds of thousands of layouts
before so what's gonna grab our
attention what do you need to draw my
eye in and then be mindful the negative
space it's not just what you put on the
page but when you put something on the
page it creates more space and it's the
white space that is really just the
balance the art and the beauty of how
the layout comes to life and lastly
we'll talk about details is letter
spacing okay did you misspell any words
is there any kind of weird alignment
issues and you kind of do it in this
order you don't just start with the
details okay having said that let's get
into the work now it was a question like
how do we pick the work that we're gonna
critique how does this work
okay I think you and I spoke last night
and are you prepared to like get your
hands into some of the work today or is
it me piloting again I'm gonna let you
do that one more time I tried last week
tie that I'm open I'm open let's look at
a few work and then let's see how that
goes but for now files - yes no we'll do
that next week okay so you guys don't
know because you probably have seen my
face before and you know who I am
Milka was many things a teacher for over
ten years at a bunch of different
schools private and state schools and
she
I worked for a period of time at
snapchat is that right mocha yes I did I
worked there for like almost five years
five years old as your role there I was
many roles actually because it was a
startup we had a flat structure but
ultimately I ended up being the head of
the brand corporate design in charge of
all the branding I also design and
co-created the logo for snapping with
the co-founder of snapchat Evan Spiegel
mmm that sounds like a pretty awesome
job how did you get that job I'm just
curious well as you mentioned I taught
about 15 years to 15 different public
and private universities and one of my
students Evan Spiegel he started a
startup company called snapchat and he
called me in and said Milkha can you
come on board and help us out and I said
I'd be delighted so Wow
teaching pays off in your case it had my
wife wondering like where's my dumb luck
and I've been teaching for a bit too so
that's pretty fascinating it's
fascinating for a couple different
reasons one is that where we are in the
world you have the opportunity to meet
young talented bright brilliant minds
like like Evan right yes and then he
takes your class and then he remembers
you so that's also a pretty significant
little thing there yeah yeah and he's
successful this is crazy young people
former students of yours are running
really large multi-billion dollar
corporations that's awesome well if you
think of it that way it is awesome it is
I was also his private design tutor so
if that helps that anybody to wanting to
take advantage of that opportunity with
your teachers I think I highly recommend
do work with your teachers privately
because it does pay off
mmm ok we'll follow up on this a little
bit more later so let's get into it
because people are asking who's Milko
who's is wonderful lady with the sound
effect
and all the colorful analogies and mixed
metaphors well that's milk of Brookline
and in case you're wondering
Naoko and I are friends we've been
friends for a really long time now we
run into each other all the time because
we live in the same city essentially but
we've never taught together we've never
worked together so it's been a delight
for me personally to be able to have
another set of amazing eyes looking at
the work and you guys know she she's so
sharp nothing that's going to escape her
so let's just jump into the layout so
this week I'm gonna start by doing
something a little different here the
feeling is mutual Chris thank you very
much thank you so I'm gonna look at Toni
Gibbs work and I just want to tell you
how I select work I scan really quickly
because there are like 30 to 50
submissions every single week and each
person is submitting through pieces of
work Mark's done a really good job of
helping me to curate ones that he thinks
are the best learning opportunities then
I have to go through those and make
decisions as to is there something good
here that I can talk about as an example
for others to follow is there one thing
that they're trying that I think other
people can benefit from looking at and
opening up their horizons in terms of
what they want to explore also I pick
layouts that are just in desperate need
of like a rethink so that's what I'm
looking for and it's at the extremes of
these submissions that I'm picking out
work the ones in the middle I feel like
we've already talked about we've seen
before or they're not pushing it so you
can push it and do something brilliant
or you can push it and have a horrific
car crash but it's just type nobody gets
hurt so it's okay that's true right so
you might see you're working like oh
yeah I'm on the good side and then you
realize oh my god I'm on the dark side
of this okay let's get into it so what I
did this week it was I took a little bit
of time to draw over a few of the
layouts so I'm gonna zoom in here so you
guys can see this okay and hopefully you
guys are seeing this and you're hearing
me clearly so one trick that I'll do and
you've seen me do this before is to draw
a block over things
I just want to simplify the layout
because if you look at the words or the
paragraphs they can get more complicated
and then you look at the words and it's
even more complicated then you look at
the letters you could start to lose a
sense of what the layout is doing so by
merely drawing a block over the elements
that Tony has laid out for us we can
kind of see now the essence of this
layout
and if you really think about it this is
just really one group here it just
happens to be broken into three parts
right but it's a very centered layout
and it is to me a little bit on the
static side usually centered layouts or
reserved for things that are very
classical and they're feeling very
traditional but this layout is neither
classical or nor traditional it's a it's
a magazine about pioneers in design so
we want to honor the content we want to
treat it appropriately so this is where
I'm having some issues with this layout
and the other thing that I get the
feeling of Tony's done here is that he's
taking the type and he's pushing up into
the corner here and he's pushed it down
into the corner here and it's it's not
doing anything for me
Naoko do you have some thoughts on this
yes I totally agree with you and it's so
good that you created those boxes so we
can visualize how the relationship is
working with one another
we talked about almost and look at
there's so many almost things that are
happening here there's almost same size
boxes they're almost same distance away
from each other it's symmetrical but
it's not symmetrical so the question is
how can we take here's a question
actually before we move forward this
class is about hierarchy of typography
what's the first read the first read is
definitely those two big gigantic Texas
on the side which I really appreciate
the student Tony pushing and pulling
that and making it interesting and
exciting and off the page but I think we
need to spend a little more time into
realizing what is my first read what is
my second rate and what is my third read
you got to look at it and go boom boom
boom we already have the sound effects
going boom boom done
you squint you squint your eyes and and
see what is the first thing you see
because right now my eye is going boo
boo it's like I don't know which
to look at it the one on the Left says
made me meet the one on the right says
me me me and I'm like whoa I'm confused
so what should we do
oh we need to deconstruct and
reconstruct let's do it let's do it
yes dr. song I'm gonna copy this and
this week what I've done is I'm gonna
just be zooming and zooming out like
this the whole time so assuming this is
close enough okay that's the layout so
this time we'll have a before-and-after
I'm doing that for a bunch of these
things I don't wanna show you what else
I'm doing here but okay
I like the laughs and we have the after
on the right so Milko walk me through
what you would do as a type expert may I
take this opportunity to talk about
readability Chris is that is that okay
yeah
folks notice that we can it's more easy
to read the right side of the page where
it says aha thank you Chris
whereas it's more difficult to read the
left side of the page exactly in general
it is easier to do so because of the
form and the shape of the letters it's
more recognizable when we see the top
half versus we see the bottom half yes
it is you guys don't know if they're
okay so that's a good note to have so if
we want to take advantage of pushing and
pulling it off the page let's see more
of the top portion of the text
oops uh-huh and then maybe slide off of
the bottom portion yeah okay Chris
you're just so good you've got it you're
talking I can do it you're so awesome
beautiful does that help
do you see how that helps that boom
already is creating that cushion pull
it's creating that debt that we're
talking about so you see the right side
of the page first and then the left side
of the page mm-hmm are you are you all
with me
we're with you awesome now the ones in
the middle they're not talking
to the right side and the left side so I
would I don't know at this moment I
would probably go in there and redesign
the whole thing exactly thank you Chris
yes the space between those boxes
they're not there for me we I mentioned
this last week when we're designing a
layout we want to be mindful of how each
element is has a relationship with other
elements they need to have a
relationship they need to talk with one
another right now they're not talking
with one another they're speaking
different languages resonate is speaking
vertically right and then the rest of
the body copy is speaking horizontally
in the middle yeah we need to spend some
time in order to make this work and
we're not there yet at all I think we
need to spend some good amount of time
to make this work Chris what would you
do from here on out what would you like
to say yeah I want just want to say a
few things and I think you're right and
that we kind of have to just hit the
reset so reset button here's what I'm
gonna buy is everybody to do you're
staring at your leg like god why isn't
it singing it's not flowing what is up
so we can try to do a few things we can
say I'm all I'm gonna do right now is
I'm gonna hide stuff okay watch what
happens I'm gonna take this I'm gonna
hide it does it make the layout better
is it still broken I'm like it's still
not great because the the center column
text here it's not really doing anything
with this they're kind of not relating
to one other not speaking the same
language to borrow Milkha's phrase there
so if I start to let me remove this okay
now you look at that and you're like is
that interesting and some ah yeah it is
right so now we think this element is
good maybe in its previous iteration
when you're hiding too much of it wasn't
so you need to see a little bit more of
the tops of the e and a couple of other
letters because see this letter here
that the G you can't tell that's a G
just yeah it could be a
our case a a weird hey or something we
just don't know so by pushing it no into
the frame we can get a better sense of
what it is now if you pull it too far
out it may or may not lose that that
tension that's being created on the left
edge there so just be mindful that now
let's bring everything back okay
so now what we do is want to do the
opposite here I'm gonna hide this I'm
gonna hide each one needs an order here
you hide this hide this okay now that I
bring this back is this okay now this in
itself is not bad and this isn't bad but
the two together isn't really doing
anything this is where you may want to
pay more attention to alignment greeting
and spacing so when we talk about this
the order like we have the focal point
but how are these things related like
once I read resonate what am I supposed
to do here this is where we need to
start the design right so if I bring
each and out see like this is what you
need to do this works true like in
Photoshop as it does in illustrator turn
off your layers turn them back on one at
a time and when something doesn't feel
right you've identified a problem so
perhaps this thing that you're doing
here which is kind of reminiscent of how
credits are displayed at the end of a
film where they split the alignment they
aligned flush right and then flush left
and then the align dings in that that
way that's kind of what you've created
here so it feels to me like Tony what we
want to do is make sure we understand
how to manipulate in position type for
impact for Claire for clarity and for
relationship and for balance and harmony
and in this initially felt like you
dropped through the elements and you're
like I don't know what else to do that's
it okay
so some things for you to think about I
think the first thing I would do just
immediately take all the stuff and align
it left okay and ask yourself is this
layout better now there you go
I can breathe now do not hold your
breath when designing everybody you'll
turn blue in the face and it's not good
we're starting to get a better sense of
the flow and all I did was hit command
shift L on the Macintosh which i think
is also control shift out on the PC
somebody correct me if I'm wrong
so that aligns everything and it's like
why did we fight this why did we try to
split this because we weren't confident
enough in that keeping this aligned is
good enough so we add tricks we do
things like that so the other thing that
we need to pay attention to is I'm gonna
draw another box here I'll grab this one
okay and I'm gonna draw a box and kind
of get a sense of proportion here so if
I take this and then drop this down here
oh doing something weird okay it's about
double so you can see like we're
creating weird spacing in between all
these things well all I want to do is
pay attention to the space in between
these boxes like the white space here
and the white space here so I'm gonna
delete these now okay sometimes that
helps so we just want to try something
we want to take this and we want to say
what if we brought this closer to this
does it make this base more interesting
or dynamic does reducing the number of
elements from four things four groupings
1 2 3 4 into 3 make it a little easier
yeah maybe not I don't know Chris if I
may add to what you're saying is that
before we have these boxes or islands
that they're floating around and by you
bringing the middle paragraph to the
bottom paragraph you're creating
proximity and proximity is a good thing
to create focal point
if it says that I jumping around boom
boom boom cuz it's overwhelming for the
eye to know where to go yeah when
there's these elements floating around
mm-hmm okay so that's the other thing
you can do is if things so complicated
make them simpler by grouping
yes position their distance implies
relationship nice if I put these two
close together then we look at this as
their family they belong together and we
should see them as one unit even though
they're made of many components okay and
we can keep working on this so you can
also say like okay
what else can we do over here I'm gonna
try something okay all I'm gonna do is
put a little bit more space between
resonate and this and see like okay how
does that change things like does this
make this more interesting so I'm gonna
get three groups back it's really small
one a little dot on the page a box and
another box okay I forgot to mention
something I want you guys to look at
this let me hide this for a second if
you were to look at this as a layout
just like you're doing abstract painting
post monitor and kind of just boxes on a
page do those boxes look interesting to
you and if it doesn't look good like
this it's probably a good indicator we
need to work on the composition a little
bit more and if you need some help
there's some artists you can study and
you can look at their their compositions
like who can they look at Tony I also
get the feeling that Tony is trying to
perhaps challenge himself to see how he
can create this symmetrical layout but
be aware Tony that when Chris created
those boxes it also showed us that what
do we see we see a window I see a window
is this what you want the audience to
see if that's the intention then again
you're on the right Road but if that's
not the intention then it's not working
out because the eye is jumping around
everywhere like how you're looking at a
window where you've got all these little
boxes and windows that are floating in
front of you with a frame okay so we're
gonna leave this here for a moment and I
promise you at some point if I get a
moment I'll look for some artists to
point in your direction and then you
guys can look at their compositions okay
all right let's move on so next up I'm
gonna hide this layer here okay
beautiful job Chris on that one very
nicely done
let's hear I have to zoom out to see it
what the heck we got here so okay let's
zoom in on this one all right this is
from he help me spell his name
phonetically so it's loot fun Kalas and
we chuck so no okay I probably should
say it a lot faster but
seeing how like my language is
monosyllabic and you give me these
polysyllabic names it's a lot harder for
me to read so it's loot fun we chest oh
no ok so when I look at this I think he
may or may not have the right typeface I
don't think he has it but I think he
left me a note so just letting you guys
know I'm aware of it ok so once again I
look at this layout and just as a
reminder this week we have more options
we've ever had we have two point sizes
and two weights you would think this is
too good to be true
and I'm seeing like this dive in the
work like last week I thought we're
going up this rollercoaster and we're
like going to a really good place to new
heights we saw some really beautiful
layouts it wasn't a whole lot for me to
do in some of the layouts and this week
unsurprisingly to MOCA and I the layouts
overall got worse having more options
man like I got more decisions to make
now you know you're allowed to use to
point sizes and to weights but you don't
have to you're allowed to so just think
about that okay all right just because
you're given 128 crowns doesn't mean you
have to use all the crowns so it turns
out those limitations are things are
good for you these constraints that we
work in so I'm gonna turn on the
highlight layer I had to turn this
yellow because otherwise you won't be
able to see what it is I'm putting on
there but this is essentially a three
column grid give or take all right so we
have three blocks that are very similar
in measurements in terms of their size
if I take this duplicate it down they're
very similar not quite but they're very
similar okay and they're butting up
against each other and it's trapping all
the space in here yeah like uh let me
breathe a little bit it's almost like
you built a house and if we're looking
from a floorplan like from top down we
have this courtyard up here in the top
left and we have this courtyard in the
bottom right but the people are playing
up here can't play with the people at
the bottom right we've given them no
space like how do we move from one place
to the other the egress and ingress in
and out of space the flow the air the
energy the Chi
we're like blocking it up so we kinda
have to figure something out there
okay no good you have any thoughts on on
this layout I agree with you a hundred
percent in fact this is a perfect
example when the designer is putting a
lot of effort into designing and then
they realize oops I got a I got a couple
of more information and I don't know
where to put it
oh look there's some space at the bottom
beam let me put it there oh there's some
space at the top left boom like that
yeah so thank you boom don't do that you
mean don't make you or don't do don't
put in the car oh no no you give me make
me a crate all due respect I'm fine with
that thank you I don't block the space
remember space is your best friend you
don't want to kill your best friend do
you you don't want to kill that space
that is giving the breathing room for
those big beautiful nice tight
typography in the middle of the page so
by putting the journal for graphic
design at the bottom right where we're
suffocating the space and then we're
doing the same thing by putting
january/february at the top-left corner
let's take those out and if we cover
those we can see how we can we can
breathe if we cover those for just a
second yeah
you want to get rid of this yeah just
just for temporarily so people can see
if you cover them how the layout looks
ah look at that oh I can't breathe now
and then if we also cover January
February just temporarily just
temporarily cover it okay thank you
alright now that I begins to flow
rhythmically right in order to push and
pull this we need to now because the box
the two that the height of the two
negative spaces are almost the same size
let's see if we can decrease one of them
and increase the other one to create of
a more asymmetrical dynamically at and
how would we do this maybe we'll push it
down a little bit okay maybe we'll make
resonate this is two sizes too weights
right maybe we can take out the hedge um
okay that's even better that's even
nice nice Chris beautiful beautiful we
can even take the whole area of eight
and the rest of the body copy and push
that up a little bit now oh no didn't
work yeah it didn't work how about this
how about with if we take features and
the remaining of the body copy and push
it up the whole entire body copy uh-huh
and then let's just see okay it's
working but then we're creating the
staircase effect we old staircase so why
don't we do this why don't we push eight
all the way up and then take the whole
entire body copy bring it down and see
what happens to that what do you think
Chris no now it's playing the piano know
exactly what you're doing I can't really
exactly what you're doing and you're
trying to like free up some space so I
have some thoughts on how to do this
please okay let's try so I thought we
were off to a good thing by saying we
free up space up at the top here by
pushing the type
down we can still read it what if we
were to either push it this way or push
it this way and just free up some space
now nice take one just for a minute I
know that we just told you like the tops
of letter forms are easier to read true
but we're just exploring the layout
right now and so now look what we've
done we've opened up the space
we haven't changed practically anything
just yet except for did shift the crop
if you will okay like this is what
photographers do they look through the
frame and they find the part that's
interesting and that's the picture that
they take are you in this case or
looking at your own layout your subject
and you're gonna just gonna crop it
differently now by doing this I think we
give ourselves a little bit more freedom
before we've talked about how to create
something that feels evenly uneven like
it has it going up and down kind of a
kind of mountaintop kind of vibe versus
the shape that we had before that's the
before and this is the after right so we
can try now maybe to take this and lower
it and see if we can create something
that's got a little bit nicer rhythm so
when we talk about space if we take this
and we separate it a little bit like
what happens and we want to explore all
these things so when you're doing this
layout at home kind of just look at your
layout to see what else that you can do
so I think milk is instinct it pushes
all the way out was a good one I just
don't know how far we can push it out
and this is also the problem with all
uppercase because the forms are very
blocky it's heavier and I think you did
this on purpose to kind of create the
skyline if you will it's like a vertical
building it's very blocky or as upper
and lowercase letters they have it's my
guess and I can't find it yeah more
interesting forms that are easier to
read they feel a little less rigid I
think there's still problems with this
so the last thing I'm gonna do right now
is I'm going to take this whole thing
and I told you guys before too you can't
change the dimension of the page but you
can't change the size of the type and
this type is probably a little bit of a
big side it could stand to be reduced a
little bit so I'm gonna reduce it down
and I think every time we make one of
these decisions kind of just start to
get a sense like oh space is starting
over I can't breathe
yeah nice job nice job read them it's
important from
debris okay and so people are asking
what was wrong with the staircase in the
beginning and how do you address looking
at staircases again staircase is a very
signified form and shape that you're
looking at it when I see a staircase
what am I thinking
staircase I'm not thinking about
resonate and salt baths and all these
other features right so the pattern of
it yeah you gotta be aware of that it's
that the unintended shape that you
create is the thing that people start to
look at and you just want to be aware of
it yeah the unintended shape exactly
mm-hmm okay so this this still needs a
lot of love guys and we're just trying
to identify some of the problems I'm not
saying that this is like a work of art
ready to hang in a modern art it's far
from it I think part of the problems do
is I don't know if this is Roboto or one
of those typefaces
but Luke London had said that he didn't
have the typeface so even in the design
of the typeface I already had the weird
feeling of this gee I just don't love
this jean just messing me up guys yeah
Chris this is a good opportunity now to
bring back those little elements that we
hit in and then use those as the
satellite to bring in okay but not at
those places yes sweet you read my mind
working on it you may be the only the
mind of the only woman that I can read
because although thank you what a
compliment is that we're the sister and
brother from different parents a sister
from another mister as they would say
our brother from another mother
okay so well we we got to work on those
guys and just just so we're having this
conversation right now I want to show
you the difference between these letter
forms so I'm gonna go and make this
thing white and rotate it look and you
got me doing sound effects now and I'm
typing eight okay I want you guys to
become sensitive to these forms the
good this G from Helvetica and this is
what G is this this is a Helvetica neue
and look at the G here with the stem and
the spur it's like it's so beautiful and
then look at this G it's flat here on
the side this one's rounded the
proportions feel better the x-height the
crossbar of this G is higher so the
higher X height than this one this one's
like right around the middle point this
one's much higher so I want you guys
become sensitive so like when you walk
into a building an art exhibition and
you see this typography on the wall
which is very functional people read
that to understand the art and artists
but you're looking at like the front of
the eye of a designer like gosh these
are just really beautiful letter forms
and it's beautifully typeset nice
spacing really good letting so those are
the things I want you to become
sensitive to okay yes if I may add to
what you just said if you bring that G
back the Helvetica G notice the spur of
the G is an error and that's how you
know that's how America do you see the
error at the terminal of the uh-huh if I
can top of it so please clearly see it
let me give it a color so that and
that's how you know that's the it's a
family of the Helvetica yes there's a
arrow coming up beautiful
that there you're talking about that's
it perfect yeah there you go
and you can take advantage of that
depending on what you're intending to do
actually like go geo yes yes go use the
arrow make it really prominent mm-hmm
uh-huh yeah you guys get the idea I'm
gonna do yeah okay so we got to work on
this a little bit more okay now I won't
look at this lad here from Joshua Gilley
Joshua Gilley is the hot mess hot mess I
have to say there's a lot of stuff going
on and I think you totally make this
layout work a couple of ideas to play
around with here but I think you took
Milkha's advice to make a tight tight
tight tight dollar I could see that but
it needs some love so let's identify
some things that are problematic I want
to give the kudos to Joshua for really
taking an idea and going all the way to
the other side because we never know
till we try it and I really appreciate
for going really tight tight tight tight
what happens here is now we need to give
it some love obviously the stroke of the
letter R with the stroke of the letter
and they're not aligned that's that's
something that it's really bothering me
right there exactly yeah when I see that
then I get the feeling that the designer
could have spent a little bit more time
I know you spend a lot of time figuring
this out but those little details also
shows that you are really aware of the
whole entire form and shape paying
attention to make it work and and
obviously up here you see there's little
things that get cut off yes
and obviously the E in the S they're not
speaking to each other it's like they're
having a car crash side sound effect
there's a big bang and then the eight
what is that behind the eggs if I may
ask is that an S here's an S okay yes
I'm not 8's present it's like reading
ass no I'm just kidding I don't know
what it says okay okay I have to say
again I like the direction that Joshua
is going yeah but it's not there yet
MMH what I was a little bit I'm gonna
I'm sorry I'm gonna give it a little bit
tough love here I I apologize because
we've talked about this you guys I've
been on this show
what is this is my third or fourth third
time okay we've already talked about
this twice about how be aware of things
that are equal amount of space so we're
doing the same exact thing here we're
dividing things up in equal amount of
space the top portion is almost equal as
the bottom space portion if we cover
features if you just put a white box
over where it says features and
everything else just a white box
temporarily thank you Chris
you're welcome the whole entire area
Chris please sure thank you all the way
through the edge at the bottom edge
continue nice beautiful okay see what do
we see we see yin yang right white space
at the top left and the bottom white
space at the bottom that's a yin yang be
aware of that space you can't just say
oh I have some space there boom I'm
gonna put some text in there and it's
gonna work itself I know there are still
fighting with each other that top space
is fighting with that bottom space risen
where where our es is is dividing it in
half almost right and we have the eight
at the top and we have the end at the
bottom maybe that's the most interesting
part of the layer
where the ate is pushed to the right and
the N is pulled to the left maybe that's
the only interesting part but the rest
is not solving itself at all I want to
give you one more kudos I like where the
january/february is sitting between the
eight and the e thank you for that
yin-yang metaphor a lot of dragons that
are gonna get you talking I like where
the january/february is sitting between
the eight and the e you might say ooh
that looks like a sandwich where the
eight is crushing the e yes but at the
same time because everything else is a
mish mosh to meat that comes across like
something that is working at this I know
there's a beautiful tension that's
happening there be aware of that
not in that pot negative way but also in
a positive way that it could work for
you but right now everything is a mush
mush or hodge podge I should say hodge
podge yep much much a mishmash hot spice
so much I don't know there's like how
many ways can we say that all right
sorry I don't know why but let's throw
it gets really dry right before these
things okay let's look at this guy's I
made a copy here the yin the yang
you know the equal and opposite kind of
thing and and it was a very sharp of
milk goes just to see that like like
that she could just see it it was so
easy for me to see I have problems with
legibility I have problems with
hierarchy and I have a lot of other
issues here so what I want to do is I
want to hide this I'm gonna hide it okay
and it should really be the opposite of
this so let's just take all this I'm
gonna break your layout it's probably
look really ugly for a while so unlock
that I'm gonna just change the order I'm
not gonna essentially I'm not going to
really change the concept that you're
having here I just want to change the
order so now at least I could read this
resonate right and it still has issues
it's got some challenges that we have to
work through and let's try this thing
where you take the type and you push it
a little bit farther so that there's a
more distinctive shape and because I
push the S so
I'm gonna bring it back luckily for us
the end is very easy to read so there's
a lot of room that we can play around
with
so when Milko is talking about before
there's little details either say that I
am paying attention or I'm asleep at the
wheel
those things do matter to us a lot and
the other question I have is does it
need to have very tight lighting like
this I'm not sure and I'm gonna just
bump it out a little bit in case you
guys are doing this on a on a Mac it's
option down arrow on your keypad right
so what happens there it's not exactly
on right now but pretend like it's
really aligned does that make a more
interesting or stronger shape or
connection I don't know I'm gonna go the
opposite way which is the hold on option
and bring it up how far can we push this
stuff before we lose all sense of
legibility okay now you be aware of the
shapes that are we're creating like
right now when we have the R and n
connected to each other
look at that negative shape that we see
between the opening between the crutch
of the of the leg of the R and the
crotch of the letter n yes you call the
crotch the crotch I call the counter yes
the open counters are connected it's
almost like a lightning bolt or
something yes no we probably could use a
little scale change here probably maybe
I'm going to try of course I may not
work my scale it down a little bit I
just want to help
Naoko breathe oxygen is important okay
so see you like we're not even changing
it that much but it's creating a
different dynamic it's a different
relationship I of course need to bring
all the other tight back we gotta work
on this a little bit more but just think
about it
now the reason why I picked this josh
was not to pick on you per se but
because I saw something super
interesting I'm gonna share that with
you right now so if I turn this layer
here the 8 and the s that you created
here it looked like something to me and
I was trying to recreate this look
really fast and illustrator but there
are other ways to create this so I just
took the letter and I chopped it up and
I well
to blight it across because I thought
there was something interesting in terms
of an idea the word resonate feels like
ripples to me like in my mind that's how
I visualize it so I just started this
process and I just took a letter and if
the title itself resonate the magazine
communicated what it meant like Cal
Cooper refers to this as a visual pun it
looks like what it means and sometimes
those are very interesting relationships
to explore so if we brought all the type
back and we just made this a focal point
it could be very interesting so I see
something here I think there's an idea
that could be born from this it's really
unresolved right now in terms of sound
like what I'm trying to do but you guys
can start to play around with that kind
of stuff I can increase the spacing go
ahead it's beginning to look edgy Chris
and I think complement that I think
that's what Joshua was aiming for it's
to make it look edgy and now even on the
Left area I see it I see that edginess
developing itself yeah
we're getting somewhere here and we like
you guys trying so keep trying but then
written learn how to bring it back from
the tricks that you're applying to it so
that it feels solid and resolved again
that's the key that's the hard part
and folks crystal it beautifully did
this is the beauty of experimental or
edgy design no one's gonna get killed no
one it's all safe it's all good so push
here's what I would say design with your
foot on the gas pedal you can always
bring it back you can always edit it out
okay and that's what Joshua is doing
he's designing with his foot on the gas
pedal but now he needs to step back and
see where can you pull and push certain
areas and that's exactly what Chris is
showing you so we don't need to use all
tricks at this point I just need to put
in a little bit information to complete
this thing I think it's this piece on
this piece
copy that rock in here and
maybe we'll we'll have some kind of
layout soon I don't know you know we
have to work out where these things go
this - is creating some problems for me
yeah it's not functional
it's not functional and it's creating
taking spaces it's visually kind of
interesting but it's not it's not
helping me here and it's it's a
challenge so everything that I add to
this layout now becomes challenges this
is the puzzle they're all delicate parts
like spinning plates the more plates you
have spinning the harder becomes for you
to balance and we've got a lot of things
going on right now so my instinct is to
make this thing super super simple
because otherwise we're gonna start
competing with this other stuff on the
screen exactly it's it's like especially
ladies you might relate to this it's
it's like starting with a clean face
before you put makeup on I could tell
you everything I'm wondering cuz you put
makeup off maybe Halloween we all have
our skincare regimen then you know so ok
good good good good
and and that's exactly what this is the
beauty of these series of exercises is
you starting with with almost no
parameters where it's only one size one
weight and you're learning about the
whole space and then little by little as
you're increasing each parameter you're
developing how I can make this even more
cook I can create more depth I can
create a visual of hierarchy so have all
of this running in your head as you're
designing step by step and you're right
this week was very very challenging and
if we don't learn those first
fundamental steps then we're gonna be
just hodgepodge throughout the rest of
the exercises and with all the respect
it was going to be like as if I'm
sinking but I'm not swimming mmm okay
all right so
keep going here I want to zoom out and
find another layout to work on Milkha
was there one that you saw that you
really wanted to work on I'll be honest
with you I saw a lot that I thought to
myself I like to point at what not to do
okay so here we are
I'll point out some things not what not
to do great I'm looking at this layout I
laid and great over it are some lines so
you guys can see here's the original
layout mm-hmm and this is from heung-min
is all I think or is that and here we go
so I've put some red lines over it so a
couple things I noticed right away like
what the heck is this little corner
thing so that's why I circled in red and
then I'm looking at the grid lines here
it seems like you're trying to line
things and at first I thought you were
cheating because Michael we're not
allowed to use shapes just yet I'm gonna
log this cuz it's annoying me right
we're not allowed to use shapes but then
it's the underscore so you kind of snuck
in there with the technicality and then
you were able to reverse the type out of
that okay mm-hmm what else can we do
here so I looked at this and I looked at
alignment every time you guys do these
off access things it's like do create
interest I get it you want to do it just
make sure it's a good layout before you
start doing that because it's infinitely
harder to work with so what I did here
this is the before this is the after I
did this right before getting on the
show here today I just changed him
things one is I reduced the scale the
type resonate down and I was able to
then push the Z off the page so I don't
need to read it twice so I lose that
little thing in the bottom and I kept
your underscore right and then the rest
of elements I reordered so when when it
looked like you were doing the features
down here and then it was wrapping
excuse me it was wrapping up to the top
there it was kind of a strange thing and
he didn't need to because it
communicates the same idea so I just
took the same grid line this is where it
gets tricky because once you rotate your
layout and I don't know the angle it
becomes a lot harder for me to work with
okay so Aaron there it is so features
and then it continues on and I wanted to
break it so that there are only three
names at the top and more at the bottom
so there's greater contrast I didn't
want it to be even like five and five
just wanted to be like three and eight
or something like that and then I know
the angle is a little bit off here but I
took the rest of your type and I just
put it along here to kind of imply the
line that goes here these grid lines
that are created so I made that type
work with the base line and that's all I
did for this layout Chris may I jump in
and add more to what you're saying I
love what you did yes that was a very
good solution to simplify that this is I
saw this layout and when I saw it I go
wow beautiful but then something was not
right about it and I thought about it
I'm good ah it's that almost again the
bottom and the top resonate is almost
sitting in the middle of the page but
diagonally so what if we push and pull
again we talked about loads of third you
guys love thirds I should say what if we
grab the whole entire composition and
move it up beautiful and then maybe a
little bit to the right place okay and
then what if we take the remaining body
copy of the artist and track well I'm
sorry I don't mean to so talk about try
I'm talking about letting and open the
letting so there's aa some so now you
see how your eye flows around goes
around
beautiful beautiful now there's one more
little thing we need to do here that
little space next next to the terminal
of the Z is bothering me something is to
take your eye out so we can bring your
eye back in with the are you talking
about this little sucker here or some
other part I'm talking about the
terminal of the shape of the Z the
terminal is the end the very end part of
the Z you don't want this yes so and the
space next to it is empty so we need a
little tiny some tiny little
line to take our eye out so then it
brings it back from the are and when we
do that day what if what if we doing
that what if we just put a like a like
maybe we can good a 2018 what's that
okay that works that that works too
that was sweet that is that works very
well I love it
talking about AG well we're gonna refine
this layout just one second here because
I I realize see this little corner here
this is our top five remember the steps
guys okay let's look at the steps step 5
to details and Milko was talking about
the negative space i lost where i was
okay she was talking about the negative
space right like she wanted to activate
this space by putting something there
and i think what we need to do is just
to ship it to the right a little bit and
some you know well as soon as i do that
i'm gonna break something else i already
know it so we can bring the knee back a
little bit if we want you okay yeah just
got chopped up i don't i'm not bothered
by that but there you go yeah those
those dude says yeah okay also you got
to be careful with how the feature is
touching the edge of the page as well
that creates attention as well so we may
have to wiggle it around a little bit to
clean that up
sure yo me with all the features yeah
maybe bring it down a little bit to
create a little space there because our
fudge just just just a features just a
tad okay yeah all right and then if we
zoom out a little bit so we can see the
comparison between the two all right
nice i would probably at this moment now
i think this is working out beautifully
the one on the right of course and the
one on the left but the one on the right
we probably want to reduce the space
between the leading of the are easy re
and then n8 they're leading
and Chris something really awesome
happened here when you zoom that is on
the left side notice how we have created
a trapped space between letter N and the
number 8 folks do you see that as Chris
is doing that what's basically talking
about Oh gorgeous Chris beautiful on the
Left design what I'm noticing is ooh
Matt please okay so I had to pick
something right yeah okay do you see
this space the trapped space that is
between n re8 and the line that's a trap
space right there Utah I'm at this space
yes mm-hmm
that's a trap space I'm like aah I can't
breathe well I might be prison so be
aware of these things maybe you meant it
maybe it is about the room the room at
the Museum about resonate did you say
that with an accent or something yes
it's a it's a French Israeli accent
[Laughter]
Specter
anyways so you can see the before and
after I think to the untrained eye maybe
before you took this course maybe you've
not had this kind of critique or
guidance in looking at type but now you
should be able to see the clear
differences and we we're not
fundamentally starting over here we're
just making some very small adjustments
but these adjustments can change
everything
yeah nice job Chris we still have that
box though on the right side that
trapped space yes I want to be doing it
to have that could we have that line
vertical designer
score yeah yeah underscore could we make
it may be perpendicular I don't know
but them so gonna make sense yeah it's a
different yeah it's a defensible then I
mean I can try I mean everything's we're
trying so this is like I think the
symbol whoo you created a pipeline I
like that a kite mmm nice but then you
have to put a little bit of a space yeah
there's someone yeah it's too thick I
don't you thick and it's kind of strange
so what we can do possibly it's just a
space as out a little bit more and then
maybe that that space becomes a little
bit more open for Milka I'm not sure but
you guys every time we move something
something else breaks right so it's
something to be aware of and we can open
it up this doesn't bother me so much so
it's probably okay for me but you guys
could try it
hey good job yeah you keep working on it
okay let's move on let's see what else I
can look at ah this one this one's
killing me right now
max Douglas so let's turn on the grid so
here's what I did I just put a box over
everything like I've been doing mm-hmm
and it's creating this strange layout
for me it's like you're cutting up the
space and then I also realize these are
not at 90-degree angles that's kind of
random and a little arbitrary and then
we have this bit here which is like I
don't there's so many different things
going on here and I'm having a hard time
resolving this one okay I think Mac I
understand I'm trying to understand what
max has done yeah he's he's saying
look at me resonate resonate you know
he's almost there max I appreciate this
conceptual I layout I look at it
conceptually because honestly
everything's like secure resonate now
what probably is bothering Chris is the
flatness of the typography this would
have been a fantastic layout for the
previous week when it was two sizes one
weight
but maybe resonate is both Adam I'm not
sure this would have been a good layout
but
now that we're here where we can use two
sizes two different ways what else can
we do to push and pull this I don't know
I think this is it is what it is for two
sizes one weight it I would probably if
I were gonna do anything but this I
would probably even make it more extreme
bring it up to the top right and again
take advantage of the law of thirds
yes there you go so when you start to
using type as illustrative elements
which is what I think this is it's lines
or arrows pointing to something you're
definitely stepping to the experimental
realm and I appreciate that
wholeheartedly
the problem I have with this is like you
didn't get experimental enough you're
you're caught in that space between
thought-out graded with functional
design and then you're trying to do
expressive type and I'll show you what I
mean I'm gonna look for something right
now so Michael I mean well looking
something maybe you can help us out and
just talk through this layout a little
bit more okay maybe maybe it's a little
bit too clean and too structured when I
one of the suggestions that I like to
give and I don't know how this can work
because we're working on line digitally
is I'm curious to know if you take a
pair of scissors and cut these up and
then take a piece of paper and then
arrange them down not so precisely but
like maybe a little bit off and you know
quirky see what happens with that that
might be a way of waking this layout up
because right now it's a little bit flat
it does have that boom one focal point
but then the rest is just like dead
silent
so if we were going to pick this up the
question is can i maybe cut and paste
what I have that would be another
exercise to try it out I love that Chris
okay autism yes I'm gonna hide this
alright so when you started getting
there like super expressive type you
might want to look up data like da da da
da Dada ISM right and topography so this
is very expressive it's it's kind of
almost like a painting with words and
letter forms and I'll show you another
example here so this is kind of I love
this stuff by the way and it's really
beautiful and it's kind of difficult to
do as you guys have seen now when you
open up what you want to try everything
gets inherently more complicated and
you're there are a lot of variables to
play with so all you have to do is look
at da da da da and you'll start to see
this kind of stuff okay
and it's very expressive like here's
another one on the grab one more and
remember it Dadaism was a movement that
was rebelling against what was before
them which was very structured and clean
without not clean but it was a very
structure and it was at a turnover time
where we were about to go into a war so
this is from Kurt Schwitters a nice
beautiful so like when we talk about
like lines so when I look at this I'm
reminded a little bit of like hey you're
going to try and push it but you haven't
pushed it enough that's the problem it's
got good potential the idea is great but
it's not there yet in terms of form
especially with typography yes yeah so
friends again ask yourself some of these
principles of design so how am I using
contrast how am I using contrast of
space and I think max is using
contractors face we push it a little bit
more contrast of position you know he's
creating is putting different directions
contrast of form right now we're dealing
with typography Direction structure size
I think what's missing here is contrast
of size we have only two contrasts
right now we're at a time where we can
use three different layers why is it
three because you got size and weight
and you've got two different sizes and
two different weights that you can start
playing with one another
mm-hmm to create density and texture
yeah so I'm gonna do something with this
okay nice it feels like this is trying
to be a part of another design like it's
really organized and then this isn't
really and it's got its own vibe this
hat has been outlined because I don't
have this typeface but I think if you're
gonna do something just try to break it
like if nothing is alignment and
everything is a little bit off just have
fun with it and see what happens nice
right so it's like now it's kind of like
expanding a little explosion there and
since this has been outlined already I'm
gonna just flip it over cuz I just
generally don't like flush right type
okay I'm gonna flip it over let's just
pretend like that wasn't flipped over I
just want to look at the shape and I
want to see if I can bring some of this
together maybe maybe just make it a
little bit more angry or expressive like
you're you're taking bits of things and
you're taping them together and you've
created something I don't know it's
still not good right what if we move it
at the top of there resonate because
because the align left' needs to have a
backbone of something good
you tell myself I got okay okay yeah he
told me to do no no it's I love which I
love how you interpret some of the
things I say it turns out better than
what I thought I Chris I don't know if
you heard me what I was telling folks is
that sometimes you might want to cut and
paste like this would be a great layout
or you just cut it up and relay it out
so it does come a bit quirky and funky
and have that vibe to it that you're
trying to create right now beautiful so
if I were to maybe put this on top oh
nice right nice I like that space
did it go behind it yeah maybe didn't
work well beautiful you can you can you
could play guys you could subtract
things nice adding something I'm just
subtracting things from it and who knows
what we're going to produce because of
this right and and I think when we say
like you you're gonna need good job good
job
oh my god wow wow that's so dynamic
beautiful so we bring this type back I
mean oh don't bring it back make it work
somehow you know what happen we created
some space here I think I could make it
work Milka actually I like this too you
know I think I could make it work like
you guys if you're gonna break it just
break it all the way but it takes a lot
of it takes a lot of design know how to
really make this thing work so what I
was trying to do here is I'm gonna paint
on this ship this man I'm gonna paint on
it so if I'm looking at this I see a
flow here and I'm just trying to get
these things to work together that's
that's what I'm trying to make work
right we get into line so you guys gonna
have a lot of fun because there's ways
to make this work and they'll give you a
little preview as to when you start to
open up options watch this see how these
things are not really related together I
just draw a little line I can start to
anchor things together imply a
relationship that may or may not exist
right I think Chris is giving you guys a
little bit of a sneak peek preview of
next week which you're using lines is it
next week
I don't know mark will tell us later but
when we get to use lines and shapes a
world the possibilities open up but we
want to be careful because until we
start to understand the fundamentals
which is what we're working on here it
may be a total disaster and we don't
want to do that right and I just want to
show you like when we start to break it
you can actually create things that do
feel like some kind of expressive piece
of art I love it the problem here is
almost always the default point size of
12 regular typeface you know the weight
and the
is this one point let me see yeah it's
almost always the ugliest so take this
and we just drop it down to say half a
point it just gets more interesting
because the lines get cooler and if we
take this watch this now
total total sidebar kind of tangent here
but what do we change it to ten points
and then things start to become really
interesting when you play with different
line weights because it's almost like a
different form of type that you're
working with okay my god I can't believe
how exciting oh my god that's just so
gorgeous I would pick I would pay for
that poster good in lieu of paying you
know sleepiness for free to help educate
the public here so you guys yes you
what's going on we're taking time from
our lives the last thing I might want to
do is to it's like we push this over but
I didn't push it enough I was thinking
of gosh
whatever let me see her just make sure I
my keyboard shortcuts are working here
is that I just break the baseline a
little bit more so that it crosses over
in a weird way there's lots of little
fun things we're gonna be able to get to
do and you see here see these little
letters peeking out beyond that it kind
of creates its own tension whatever okay
so and we're gonna break break it all
the way it's what I'm saying
and you might be shocked the Internet's
gonna be mad at us Milkha mm-hmm I've
had this happen many times before
because most people on the internet
don't have formal training they don't
have the rigor the the program that you
and I have been able to go to we're both
very privileged to go to an amazing
design school Art Center yes and study
under masters of design and what you do
is you start to learn all these rules
and then when you know how it works you
also know how to tweak it and break it
and then make it something really really
cool like instinctively cuz I've done
this thousands of times I know what to
do but what the internet does is they
learn a few rules then they're like oh a
line and centered and balanced
proportion and scale so when they see
something like this they're like ah I
don't get it Chris made it worse like
saying I even legible right now this is
exactly like what
talking about classic music you hear
classic music and you go I don't get it
but then a good classic music is just a
masterpiece and that's exactly what you
created Wow
well we're working on something here and
this is the difference like people can
really appreciate photo-realistic
drawing and rendering because it looks
like something they they recognize and
they know yeah to me I've always
appreciated the abstraction as the
Cubist's the Dada's who really broke an
image to show something that has their
hand in it yeah I may I add one more
element to this is that is that you
can't take a design like this and apply
it to let's say your client is People
magazine or Fortune magazine you can't
do that
this is not the right audience like you
have to be aware who's the right
audience right now at the audience for
this for this category are architects
designers and that's why you can get
away with pushing it to the abstractness
of it and making it even more exciting
because that's what artists do they push
the edge of the envelope yeah some do so
now I'm looking at this more like a
painting unless like functional
typography but yes we digress so let's
keep going so I want to take a quick
break here because we have 34 lovely
people have joined us now we've grown by
four people who are part of this amazing
community and people who are aspiring
typographers I want to turn over to you
guys for a second you guys have a
question I mean you're here you're live
with us I want to take advantage of the
fact if you can just raise your hand
your digital hand or just make some
movement like this and then mark will
then message you or we okay there we go
who's that came read your name good I
meet yourself and Lou hey hey actually
yes thanks again for reviewing all over
it really helps me to understand how I
can approve my designs
I however find myself often going into
monkey mode and trying every possible
option to see what works I think that's
you used in one of the videos in oh can
you explain maybe what the steps you
take in your mind when you take a step
back and look at where you are yes yes
yes and I'm gonna answer that but I'm
gonna throw the ball to Milkha first I
know I do that on purpose I saw you
reaching for something like right now no
could you hear the question
no please repeat okay so basically he's
like I have so many options that he gets
into monkey brain Modi's like just like
throwing stuff like I don't know what to
do I could do so much he wants to know
the process that you go through when
you're designing something so that he he
might pick up a clue here so look what
do you do okay thank you for asking that
question beautiful I think we touched
based on this a few minutes ago is the
way I like this is what this assignment
has taught me is whenever I'm confused
is always start from one size one weight
the least amount of parameters as
possible
I do the layout and then from there I
start to cook it what do I mean by start
cooking it I push and pull it by using
different sizes I push and pull it by
using different ways again contrast is
very much the mother of it all contrast
of space contrast of size contrast of
weight and so on and so forth
so you have to really get those elements
down first before you can progress more
forward that's one area practicing area
number two is you have to be a visual
literate just like a writer who reads a
lot in order to become a better writer
as artists and designers we need to look
a lot we need to see a lot of visual
work done by different design as an
artist so we can become
visually more literate so history of
design is a very powerful class to also
take in conjunction with what you're
doing right now and both of this can
really feel one another and of course
then there's feedback that you get from
other people to improve your work so
these are some of the basic suggestions
that I like to give you to get you going
if you're ever confused alright thank
you very much for doing that and I'll
allow you to finish reaching for
whatever here continue and folks here's
the other thing you know how it's so
much easier for us to give feedback to
other people it's because we're not
looking at it subjectively we're looking
at it objectively so look at your work
objectively what if it's somebody else's
work not yours
cut the umbilical cord and you'll be
surprised how you'll see so many amazing
solutions right in front of your eyes
that's not it more like a bottle being
open when you say cut the middle I
imagine any more like us I don't know
what that is that's like the tape okay
you know what we started 11 it is now 12
25 or an hour and 25 minutes we start a
little bit late but let's pick up the
pace a little bit first I want to say
something - Cole Fraser who could not
join us because you know why Cole
Fraser's having a baby's a new dad
congrat you know as soon as his wife
delivers or maybe the baby's out and he
gets gets a little bit of sleeps and
catches a little shut-eye
oh it looks like he's on actually he's
on well what are you doing here Congrats
Cole
okay now here's yeah if Cole design
love to talk about his work here it is
let's talk about it okay call I I love
how thank you Chris there are some
beautiful things that are happening with
your design first of all I want to focus
on the top-left corner that area where
you have the Journal of graphic design
resonate
what a beautiful grouping you've done
here this is what I'm talking about
relationship there's a relationship
between the Journal of graphic design
and resume and I love how you're using
two different sizes and two different
weights good job good job this is what
I'm talking about at this moment this
area is a bit of an island for itself
and then I like how you did use a very
very light text for the remaining which
is in this issue graphic does the
graphic discourse la la la let's come
back to that later and then let's move
towards the bottom portion of your
layout and I love how it's nice and
tight typography and you're starting
bold in contrast to light and you have
snuggled the word feature right between
the s and the L in the word Saul
yes you're really paying attention and I
can tell you're having a good time by
the way folks here's another trick if
you're not having a good time you're not
doing it right and I'll bet you anything
Cole was having a good time doing this
and if you're feeling frustrated that's
a good thing because frustration
promotes you to even take more action
and to figure out and solve problems
right Chris that's right
[Laughter]
so if we zoom out a little bit and I
called what a beautiful little detail of
what you have the date in light and then
the 18 involved but here's what's
happening now the question is how we can
take all these different elements at
different places bring them together
from a focal point of view and let them
speak away from each other
aha yeah thank you Chris you are so good
at understanding exactly what I'm
talking about it's brilliant if you just
translate visually awesome so Chris what
I would like to do is I want to see how
I can bring the backboard I see a
backbone where the name of the artists
are and I see where resume is them
somehow what I want to do is I want to
probably rotate it or if not rotate it
bring the resonate where it speaks to
the bottom area of that backbone area so
right now we're not the whole resonate
area exactly if we group that and then
somehow we have them talk to one another
[Music]
look at that that is just so damn sexy
my wife said yesterday's wow wow wow wow
you're just brilliant with just two
clicks boom I can't believe it okay
Chris how would you take care of the top
portion where it says in this feature
because that's right now it's sitting as
a sign oh yes you know what I started by
silo pieces I said we don't want tears
for them you don't we don't I don't know
I'm having connecting it let's let's
have a beer rotate it vertically 45 dick
rotated 90 degrees awesome and then
maybe align it with Saul Saul Bass
resonate or somewhere
yeah you wanna align it cap oh no I like
which way you were going oh where was I
going yeah yeah I just your intuition is
just so amazing that's edgy folks you
know what forget about design you just
hired Chris and I will do it okay
maybe we should talk about that for a
second you can't hire me because I'm
just not available and I'm probably way
too expensive right but Milka I mean
you're available because you are a
creative director design director for
our company if they need you how does
one get in touch with you I mean look
guys let's just be real I'm talking
about business for a second here
MOCA is out of the goodness and her own
heart just being very gracious spending
an hour and a half two hours with us for
three weeks now it's six hours overtime
that she just can't get back but so I
need to mention we're that without
getting compensated yes poster from this
for me later
a PDF like okay but so if you're a big
company you're big corporation you need
an amazing designer with her kind of eye
her trained eye how did they get in
touch with you mocha I love that I would
you know one thing that I really enjoy
is to empower people
I love co-creating with people and
that's exactly what we're doing so I
won't come in and like you know do the
whole design for you no no no no you do
the design and then you know like Chris
and I or I come in to where I can
empower you even further I would love to
work with you if you need somebody to
come in and help you out Chris I maybe
we can put my information at the bottom
of the description where they can reach
me through Instagram Milka dot Brooking
they can reach me on my facebook public
account which is Milka Brooking design
and of course there's my website Milka
dot design but try to if you can reach
out
with me either through LinkedIn
Instagram and my public figure on
Facebook that will be awesome then we
can see how we can reach out to one
another and how I can help you yes but
you have some rules you have some rules
and we should talk about your rules okay
what were they well because you're not
exactly a social media Beast so like
getting hit with a thousand requests for
connections and it's just too much for
you to deal with this is what I'm used
to and this is what I'm built for so
when people reach out to you it's it's
overwhelming so I think some of your
rules are please remind her what you're
interested in how you know her because
it's she's coming through hundreds of
messages now and it's just so much she
only has professional connections people
that she actually knows in real life so
this is very difficult for her so be
sure you include some kind of thoughtful
note keep it short and sweet and be very
clear so the other thing that people
don't know is that as you mentioned
before you do do private tutoring for
designers know it's not cheap but if you
guys need it if you're in a position to
I'm sure you guys can work something out
okay so I just want you guys to be aware
that I don't want to go without being
said and it's whatever
christow charges I'll charge the same
[Laughter]
she refuses to undercut me ladies and
gentlemen
so we have to support each other so
there's there's no no undercutting in
this line of work okay this is perfect
you guys know my rate it's $1,000 an
hour so you work something out okay
while we were talking I just played
around with the layout a little bit I
don't think I made it better but I
realized something when we looked at the
layup this way the thing that we need to
read the most the thing that's hardest
to read is on its side so I kind of have
to [ __ ] my head to the left to read it
so I just thought like maybe we should
just try rotating a little bit so it's
the same idea it's the same concept but
it's a little easier for me to read
because now I only have to turn my head
to read these little parts versus all of
this so that's one thing that I would do
I think the layout still needs some help
it needs some work and I don't know yet
what we need to do to it but it's good
to SPECT that there's too
spacing and all these things yeah you
know Chris I'm gonna challenge you on
this uh in fact if we zoom out a little
bit for me when if this was rotated yes
on a vertical axis it did not work at
all I was like oh my god what happened
here I think the reason it's working the
other way around it's because all the
beautiful white space where the gravity
is pulling it down is helping with these
lines that they look like they're plants
that they're sprouting out of the ground
and these are artists they don't need to
be mainstream regular reading direction
they can have a different direction and
to me right now what it resonates it's
like as if a seat has been planted and
we've got some bass growing art we got
less bill growing up you know growing
out of the ground and so on so forth
dude Azinger which was I was DJ blue
dancing here as one of your teachers
yeah but this is lewd or ceman but yeah
sorry you know them no I can't okay all
right Ella's iski and so on so forth so
maybe that's why it's working and I like
what you're doing with on the left side
you're definitely on the right track
it's no time yes
you're so amazing I don't really care
about the in in this issue where it's
sitting right now uh-huh it's right now
Oh what if we rotate that vertically in
a vertical direction and have it aligned
on the back of the other that's on the
baseline of resonate aha but then could
we could we rotate it 180 degree please
yes ah yes and then have it yes
something like that
you're like a verticality yeah deadlines
are too many they're too many lines
right now
maybe we need its orders we have one two
three four five maybe three lines oh yes
good job good job
ah so beautiful this
is what we're talking about having that
spine so you have that spine and you've
got these arms coming out okay so look a
couple of tweaks here I think it still
needs some more I'm still feeling
something it's not resolved obviously we
these layouts take a lot of time to get
right for sure so I'm gonna put this one
back in because I think really like this
one
and this is like where you guys can see
a difference of opinion preferences and
it's totally okay it was like it's not
one way of doing anything so I think I
see it needs a satellite now that I see
that it needs a little science satellite
where the longer okay we can reduce the
size oh no leave that leave that where
it was actually but then we need
something maybe we can just draw a line
just for the sake of it but it we need
it at the top yes something vertical and
then maybe now we need to move it to the
right to the left to see how our I can
flow in and out now maybe a little bit
to the right
maybe half an inch yeah somewhere and
then to the top it's right nights in the
middle how about we move it all the way
above the name of Paul Rand around
somewhere around that vicinity yes
good job good job a little bit longer
perhaps but do you see how this is
beautiful this is where your eye goes in
and out you see that it's like in and
it's just the eye is rotating all around
the page you want to use the maximum I
view around the whole entire page we
don't have a dead space now if we didn't
have that line above Paul ran then the
white space would be a dead space but
now we activated it by having that
little satellite picking through does
that make sense yes so I think I know
how to maybe if you like this I'm gonna
pause it to propose that you just do it
with typography yes
all right so that we don't cheat because
the designers like well they made it
work as it cheated ha ha ha perhaps you
can just make this yes nice job nice job
nice job maybe I would be even more
refined
I would probably switch the 2018 with
January I will put the 2018 up there and
move the January where it was before all
right
I don't know oh that looks good - Wow no
no yes yes yes yes and then let's do the
2018 now I love all this sir and if it
is stuff that you're doing Chris I guess
when you don't have use of your hands
these accidents are just so good oh my
God look at that I see so much movement
this is such a dynamic sexy laughs can I
say that word is that ok I know it's
YouTube it's was another pocket war to
say sexy is okay okay yeah
okay you can say hot all right hold
Fraser congrats for being dad and for
sticking it through and joining us and
still so responsible for getting
homework done I appreciate you man and
good luck with that child
I think there's there's pressure I want
to address this because people have been
saying this like oh I don't get my thing
critiqued I feel like what would I need
my work critique here's the problem no
gun chime in if you have a different
story or experience in this one of the
reasons why I attribute my ability to
learn design faster than most of my
classmates is this one thing so this is
the part you really really need to pay
attention to is I noticed that each week
and the instructor and keep in my case
was a gentleman named Simon Johnson
British designer I had the same teacher
he would critique the work and people
would only pay attention it was their
work yes your crit was over I could see
him staring out for lala land they would
exhale just a deep breath like oh I'm
done but for me it was a little
different every person he was critiquing
I treated it as if it were my work so
instead of getting one crit I got 20
crits every single class and how did I
know this I don't know they were not
paying attention because the very next
week people would come to class they
would do the exact same thing that Mary
or Bob or Drake or Billy had done the
week before that's how he knew they
weren't paying attention
if Simon specifically said do not censor
your type watch the rag next week
there'd be six people
senator type didn't watch the rag it
happened over and over again what he is
to learn from what to do what not to do
and this is a very safe place to do this
so even if you didn't do that work if
you looked at it like what did I learn
from this and you applied it to your own
work you would grow by leaps and bounds
what we're seeing in this week is we're
seeing people repeat the same mistake
over and over again type is too big not
conscious of the three reads big medium
and small they're using typefaces or
point sizes that are too big there's no
relationship there's a lot of broken
relationships people are or the elements
are talking to each other so you see it
happen again and again so for the
purpose of how I think you should learn
lean into every one of these critiques
treat it as if it were yours
and you'll learn so much more
we're talking about Kristina's work in a
second but so what so what if your fad
or Johnny treat it like it's your work
okay
no did you have a different experience
that's exactly why I don't don't put
names of the students on the work
because I don't want to know who did it
because it's about the work and that's
something I said at the very first week
is when we look at these we want to look
at them as an exact exercise to learn
from them it's not about you okay it's
about the work and that's exactly why I
said cut the umbilical cord because we
don't want this to be about you what is
about to be about the work you're
absolutely right Chris it's we're
learning from each example and one thing
that I was hoping to see is to see a lot
of things that we've already talked
about implemented into the work and I
hope to see that in the following week
and thank you for bringing that out
Chris hi pleasure so we're gonna talk
about Kristina's work a second here
again did somebody else have another
question that we can help answer why you
guys are participating with us live on
this call yeah we had a question on if
we're gonna get any content regarding UI
for web or other other formats field for
me promise you I will or something yeah
well I think people just they're they're
probably working on a lot of UI web type
projects but just wondering if there's
anything that is coming up for those
four nuts no because we're just strictly
working with type and page layout right
now and if you're doing dealing with UI
I think a lot of the things that we're
sharing with you are probably not
appropriate because it makes it harder
to read in what place should be
intuitive right Chris actually maybe we
can put a class together for that cuz I
I totally understand the demand for good
typography on mobile and web and UI
mm-hmm I totally get it to the the thing
is with the page layout here you're
gonna get the most bang for your buck in
terms of dealing with a lot of
type in being able to work free of the
some of those constraints but what's
definitely you're gonna start to maybe
look at the relationship for the menus
and the pages that you design and
understand the contrast in weight the
positioning and spacing and we see this
a lot actually when you see people
setting up a blog post they'll they'll
make the headline maybe it's too big or
too small relative to the body copy the
byline the date that was published all
those kinds of things is almost
literally like what we're doing right
now yeah a lot of times I'm bugged by
this a lot of typesetting the default
the letting is just to open for me it's
wasting really valuable real estate but
it's creating all these white bars
underneath every line of copy so pay
attention to that and and folks just so
you know you're building confidence with
typography right now and when you learn
the rules then you can break the rules
one thing about designing typography for
web is that yes you're right things are
more structured in that area but the
more you practice especially the
fundamentals of what we're teaching you
okay the more you'll have more confident
to know what to do with your typography
before web design layout and again we're
here to help you if you're interested in
working with us from a private
standpoint or we can Chris and I can
talk about putting a class together in
that respect but that's something to
talk about okay so I in in the meantime
we worked on this okay and whoever asked
that question since I can't read it
right now if you have a follow up
question and maybe refine it a little
bit maybe I can answer a little bit
better yes this is what we're focused on
right now so I don't want to take our
focus off that so I laid some gridlines
on top while we're waiting nice want to
talk about Kristina's work there's some
really crazy angles going on here but
they're not crazy enough where it's
totally just like this the other layout
that we had worked on where everything's
busted in weird angles they're just a
little bit on a little bit off which
really just messes me up you see that
right here like these lines are parallel
I think almost yeah no it looks like
they're converging down here and there
opening up on this side I can you just
draw sloppily I don't know but I can
tell for sure this one's a little bit
off and how do I know if I look at this
well holy cow okay a little bit
different time but there's some issues
there okay my wife reminded me don't get
so technical on these things I won't get
too technical I these things don't
bother me as much because I feel like
well I I really wanted actually
acknowledge the effort the designer put
into doing this I really want to give
that kudos this is not easy
I'm sure to put a lot of love into this
and they had probably some fun and some
frustration these things can be refined
and finessed as we move forward but the
question is how can everything else
speak to one another because right now I
feel like Christina's been so much
precious time TLC towards the graphic
design but then the remaining body copy
it they're like uh I'm out of fuel I
don't have any more gas I don't know
what to do with them anymore so
Christina if you were to go back to
finish this lay out one more layer what
would you do I'm curious to know that is
she on right now mm-hm she might be okay
nevermind Christina this is for everyone
[Laughter]
okay just kidding
go ahead well we in say something Milka
no no I this is a good exercise for
everybody to think about it what would
you do if you were Christina how would
you resolve this problem how would you
create a relationship between graphic
design and the remaining body copy you
are you teasing us or will you
eventually tell us oh I like to make
people think okay so so it's just
something to think about because here's
here's the here's what I believe in
Chris if I give the answer one ear in
one ear out you won't remember it
right what do you say good job good job
but but when you ask a question then you
start thinking about it and then you're
what you're doing is you're putting the
responsibility upon the listener for
them to take action and be more
proactive rather than being passive
giving them the answers because we're
not there for them all the time are are
we no just once a week yeah once a week
so they need to figure out on their own
what would Milkha say well with Cristo
say no Co would say cut the umbilical
cord yeah and and she would say tight
tight tight I I too appreciate like what
you've done here and and I think Milko
nailed it she's like in the mind of the
designer well you spent a lot of energy
effort like why don't we look at this
like oh my god what the heck is going on
here how do you even work with that for
me it's like whoa it's like a bowl of
spaghetti spilled out on the floor so I
think after that you got exhausted and
like I don't know what to do with the
rest and it's really if you go crazy
it's like how do we make this work
how do we bring it together and so all I
did right now is duplicate one of the
crazy layers remove the mask that you
put on it and I just started to play
around with spacing and letting to make
this almost look like a logo lock up so
I personally just don't even think you
need to cut this thing up I don't know
if cutting it up adds anything I think
choosing to focus on the word graphic
design was an interesting direction for
you to head down and I just don't know
if it needs that much more okay so
cutting it up into a thousand pieces I
just don't know if it really
fundamentally added or gave you too much
for what you put into it I'm sorry to
interrupt
I when I saw everybody's work this week
I could tell that everyone was inspired
by what she did last week remember you
took that paragraph and you cut it in
half and you pushed and pulled it I can
see a lot of that inspiration in
people's work so I really want to give
the kudos for trying that out okay Chris
you're an inspiration you reminded me of
it I totally forgot about it yeah so
we're gonna show you tricks and then
once you try them you're gonna like okay
now what do we need to do I want to show
you one other trick or an idea okay yes
and then next week we're gonna have
horrible ads because I've pointed you in
the wrong direction I have not been a
good teacher here so I'm gonna match
this base line which is what I've done
here okay and I'm gonna see this may be
horrible this is always a chance that'll
be horrible and I'm okay with that and I
liked how Milkha described the process
of the struggle as an indicator like hey
you're moving into an uncomfortable
space something good may come out of
this I don't know
so I've taken that and I'm gonna just
try it look we can't add things but we
can surely subtract things and this may
be a lot easier for us to play around
with them what she was doing I don't
know yeah okay
that the subtraction of things also can
create a lot of visual interest and what
are we doing we're essentially taking
each of these letters I'm making it
twice as complicated by splitting them
and a half but there's also something
here that a famous artist jean-michel
Basquiat would always do he would cross
out words and I watched a film about him
the documentary Nast I'm like why do you
cross out words what's that because when
you cross things out it makes you feel
taboo like it's forbidden it makes you
even more curious as to what's behind it
that's why I think lingerie or certain
like striptease is very interesting to
men because if person was just standing
there naked it would kind of just be
okay I seen it there's nothing left but
now I have to use my imagination to fill
in the gaps and that's where some of the
tension comes in now granite is not very
easy to read or maybe even arguably
impossible to read but if you were able
to read it you would kind of be rewarded
you in your mind you back oh I got it I
wonder how many other people figured it
out nice I like that there was this ad
many years ago for Honda and they did a
bunch of vanity plates vanity plates are
custom license plates and they're often
coded messages and it was that one of
the highest performing ads of all time
because they had a screen full of
license plates and you'd sit there and
you'd figure it out so whereas the
average ad got like half a sec
every time this thing goes off the
charts and mints because people are
trying to deconstruct and figure it out
because when you figure it out you feel
like you're in on the joke you feel like
you're part of the club the cool kids
and Chris how many exercises how many
variations are the students are asked to
do every week I know I think they're
supposed to do ten but there's only
submit three okay they're supposed to do
ten but they're submitting three best
three their best the best three I'm
curious to know how many of them really
do all that I'll do the entire ten if
not more well we have some of them here
but they can answer that question for us
so some of you that are tuned in that's
okay here's here's my philosophy I
always encourage my students actually to
do twenty I know
whoopee whoopee yeah he's a different
sound effects sound effects to me okay
thank you folks
you'd be surprised what an effect that
creates on you when you do twenty
studies have shown I took a scuba-diving
class and I remember that they used to
make us I go deep dive deep down into
the swimming pool Olympic swimming pool
size and swim all the way across the
swing call with only three breaths and
we did this 17 times every day okay
every every class time why because they
believed that when you are underneath
the water okay you don't want to think
how I'm gonna survive you want
automatically boom to remember what to
do okay so they taught us a lot of
tricks to do under the water but we did
it 17 times every time because they
wanted to embed us embed that in us so
one of the reasons that I asked my
students to do this at least 20 times is
because I would ask them to come to the
class with their
fifteen this way I knew they at least
did it sometimes somewhere between 15
and 20 and it has become embedded in us
you'd be surprised that how when you do
so many it becomes like as if you're
drinking water easy sweet simple nice I
tried something like that and did not do
well when I tried one time Milka
you know you got to answer your question
a lot of people have done 10 some fewer
but there's people have done up to 20 so
good kudos to those people yes good job
good job good job good job keep it up
keep it up because the more you try the
more you are going to learn it's
practice okay you need to say that in a
rhyming kind of way the more you try
[Laughter]
we're not MCS we're not battle rapping
here today and more you try the more
you're doing has become fly oh I like
that the more you try the more design
becomes flying okay what else what else
we doing okay III I don't see these
pieces talking to one another
I see Islands I want to see these every
element needs to talk to one another why
because it's not about you you you me me
me it's about the whole thing together
working together as a unity yeah
as a unity as a unit okay so as we
struggle with count skills here this is
why we're so creative even come up with
creative language description there's a
I'm trying to find my brush in my
pattern library here just to show you
what else we can do but okay I totally
broke the layout just wanted to show you
we probably need to just maybe talk
about a few all okay we need to talk
about Keith Cox Keith Keith we have some
issues we're struggling here we have a
block okay this is what I mean
let me grab
their element here that's exactly the
one we've talked about this multiple
time this one we've talked about this
multiple times
I remember one specifically from last
week I'm sorry I'm sorry kid I don't
mean to give you tough love I apologize
but we want you to improve and we talked
about how things are recognized speaking
in different direction
we've got horizontal they've got
vertical and we've got diagonal and then
got boom dead space at the bottom Keith
what were you thinking is this a
rhetorical question or do you want Keith
to actually answer he's on right now no
I wanted to get I wanted to be inspired
to think and maybe next week we can
break in pushes work even further based
on what we have suggested kids give us
some feedback are these feedback working
for you are these making any sense
if not let us not house we can help you
to push your work even better okay so
what I'm gonna do right now is I'm gonna
take this Keith because I think Milkha's
asked you a couple of questions boom and
now we have to kind of answer them okay
so I'm gonna shoot I missed that part up
Keith we have Chris here he's gonna help
you not sure if he's on here let's see
III don't think I mean there's no
guarantee to anybody that's emitted
stuff is okay nevermind Keith everybody
once again everybody yes Chris has all
the answers okay so I have some no no so
here we go
it's like something like that okay more
than so when I look at this if this were
an abstract painting how much would you
pay for this painting
would you want to hang this in your room
a beautiful modern art and architecture
I don't know
so the proportion the the the
relationship it doesn't seem like
there's a relationship Keith so this is
one of those things where you really
need to lean into some of the critiques
that we're providing and apply that to
what you're doing I'm not seeing
relationship between these three things
and what we were doing is we're cutting
off space so you've taken this space
here
which is like nice pick it open and you
just made it smaller by cutting it off
and just making it smaller and smaller
and it's hard to deal with and then this
seems like I have an element I'm just
gonna jam it in here I don't know what
to do with it and Chris may I
acknowledge that kids efforts in
creating two different sizes and two
different weights because if you look at
the top portion I can tell you spend a
lot of time trying to figure out how to
use these different parameters you see
my re re Z is in bold and a is in light
and then he's got the different size at
the bottom journal graphics I see he's
got it all with different elements but
then all three of us the question is all
these three different islands as you are
describing it to everyone how can they
relate to one another and speak to one
another yeah so if we wanted to if we
wanted to there's a couple other things
too I think you're using more than the
two weights that your you were given so
this is I think come on this is light
nice this is bold nice this is italic so
right there you broke it because there's
three now and you're not supposed to do
that right so that's that's something so
if we were to take this and let's make
it conform again it's like you have too
many ingredients you ranch the pantry
yes the cook-off and you grab too many
things and you threw it all in the stew
and it was just too much
nice nice nice analogy too many salt and
pepper just too many things you're
throwing it all there okay and the stews
coming out it's like it's confused a
little bit the thing that we talked
about before is if you're struggling
with your design just do this one thing
just make the point sizes smaller just
make them smaller I'm also seeing here
okay all right it's 12-point type the
default point size which we said in the
first week do not use the default point
size do not use the default weight of
regular it's the ugliest one that you
can find so watch what happens I'm not
gonna change anything I'm just gonna
make it smaller by Mickey
and point and the Milka at some point
she's gonna say her classic line okay so
that's ten point hide this take this
again now let's just make it oh my
goodness Wow what size is that now you
know that's eight point type now okay
yes the thing that we need to do is I'm
gonna say this pretend kid is gonna be a
crazy analogy I've never used this
before
pretend you're the host to like a
slammin party you're the person throws
parties that celebrities come to then
you have these three friends and all
awkward and introverted like normal
designers right you have these friends
yeah why is this group ungroup this okay
you have this friend you have this
friend and you have this friend and this
friend but none of them are talking to
each other
mmm right and what they're doing is
they're being Wallflower she guys one
time what ones being wallflowers they're
standing by the wall the party's
happening inside the space everybody's
like having a great time and this friend
you just sitting here by the wall so I'm
gonna show you something
hey hey come over here hang on over here
a little bit hey friend come in a little
bit just come in oh okay even you weirdo
on an ankle you could just exist so by
just introducing them to the rest of the
room and the guests you have to create
an interesting relationship so that's
what we should try to do okay so I'm
gonna bring this sucker back this friend
is just hogging up all the attention and
blocking the exit yeah friend friend
you're making uncomfortable for
everybody
step back a little bit keep probably
some space talk a little bit quieter and
maybe maybe we could have a good time
well what if he's the host the host
should not be here the host should just
everybody feel really comfortable in my
opinion right okay right you're gonna
say something profound I feel it I love
your analogy good job beautiful I
learned from the best
thank you Chris thank you you're the
best okay so we're gonna keep working
out okay Keith so let's pay attention
next week explore the smaller point size
of this and see if you can get your
friends to talk to each other in a way
that's you know using the rest of the
space and I know you can make it work
youth we want you to get better we know
that you have it within you so let's do
that okay I didn't get a whole lot but
it was can I make a suggestion please if
you're ever stuck on a work that you
don't know if it's good or not here's my
suggestion you've got at least 10
exercises that you can do take one of
them and make it really bad purposely
purposely make it really really bad and
look at it and then this way you know
where to go where not to go
does that make sense yes because because
right now this is what I said this
earlier design with your foot on the gas
you can always subtract right now you're
focusing a lot of the work that I see
with everyone everyone everyone at this
moment is that I see a lot of beautiful
focus in certain areas beautiful focus
in certain areas beautiful focus in
certain areas but not all is still in
sync with one another take that layout
copy and paste it and do something that
you've never done before have them talk
to each other in a weird way see what
happens then this way you know if you
draw a line how far to go and how far
not to go keep talkin oka okay so let's
keep going no no speaking of small point
sizes somebody had a layout here where
it's like oh my god when we tell you you
go small from Carol Daly this is a very
interesting layout okay you look at it
like there's something really beautiful
minimal yeah this black square which are
not allowed to have just yet okay well
we can use shapes and lines you can do
that but the reason why this looks so
good right now is because they use this
type that's so small and they actually
checked it out what size is it first of
all let me ask you what sigh this is
except
will tell you milk up for print you have
to figure out who your audience is
because at different age you want to be
mindful of using different size point I
have used six point type butts still
readable if there's a lot of tricks into
it that you have to apply in general
eight point looks gorgeous but for some
certain audience it does it's not
readable they have to swing their eyes
and they can't read it so in print and
print high-quality printing good paper
for the certain audience I think the
bottom end is gonna be about six point
type this ladies and gentlemen is four
point type O so on on a screen a
high-definition screen a 4k screen and
six 8k for screen whatever you got you
might say like it's fine
and it's a beautiful layout it really is
it's like well-balanced or some
interesting things going on there's
definitely big medium and small going on
here big medium and then small right
you jump I have that but you've done it
in a way that you've gone beyond the
parameters in terms of like legibility
because if you were to print this thing
out it would be next to impossible to
read okay so it's something we want to
think about obviously Kyle knows how to
design he knows to make this work but I
want you to try to make it work within
the parameter so I would just take this
and change it a 6-point type okay the
layout okay it's funky and broken
already but yeah you can see that you
need to work on that okay so what I
would suggest you do is just use the
space a little differently you can make
it work oh my god that's just brilliant
okay you can make it work then then you
could take this there's it's not aligned
Chris are they using a grid that you
provided them I don't know if I included
a grid but okay cuz I see a lot of grids
with everyone's work yeah then I'm not
definitely was a lecture on grids
whether they're using it correctly or
not I don't know yeah
yeah so what I need to do is fix this
what was scary yeah I don't know again I
don't want to focus on this too much but
sometimes the way you build your file it
works against you like right now I came
and move this because all these things
are linked together and just not
necessary maybe it's this one that's
okay just a heads up for hit in two
hours we're hit in three hours we're
we're past it five hours now okay okay
so we can make this work if we scaled it
up it could work okay so Kyle I get the
sense that you know how to design but
you're breaking the rules in ways that
yours
you still have to work within the
parameters were given and then break
those rules inside of it but not not
invent your own rules can I add one
quick little suggestion to this Chris
and I'm sure you'll agree I would take
the word resident the N and eight I
would love to see the stroke of the N to
be aligned with the body copy you know
what I'm talking about
yeah so you may have to move the top yes
ah that looks so clean and organized a
lot of for like British or Swiss or
European design you'll see things like
this yes this design Swiss design and
bold and light being paired together
with like simple shapes like this and
you could see like if I were to
introduce color this thing would just
pop right yeah give me a hot pink or
something you've seen things like this
yeah all right
okay I think we're gonna need to wrap
pretty soon so I'm going to quickly scan
and I'll just talk real fast okay let's
talk about some of these layouts so
Valentin DeVoe I think you have some
similar issues here where it's just
three things for things that are
separate they're not talking to each
other let's pay attention to that and I
think we need to kind of use the space a
little bit smarter than this okay this
is Chris Jensen
Chris's news
the really tricky here I don't even know
how you did this these probably putting
things in a box and getting everything
to fit and flow from one thing to the
next
it is borderline like even legible so
it's really working on the shapes but I
can tell something with Chris is that he
understands proportion he understands
the different weights that you can
create it's just pushing legibility yeah
we painting with shapes I feel that has
a lot of potentials I can see that for
some maybe maybe a big wall paper
he's creating a pattern cares to see
more of his work beautiful okay so we
talked about Christina our dis posters
are this magazine someone's asking these
are magazine covers theoretically that's
okay it's actually really nice okay it's
got one strong axis here this was well
everything works off of it she's using
the the two point sizes really well
first name last name all caps and
differentiating lower case upper lower
case and all caps to create different
textures and visual weights that you see
on screen okay I think she also treated
this really smart because this is the
only one that's two people odermatt and
TC or two people so good job on that
maybe the relationship between these
need to be straight yeah that's yeah you
can think up where you could take
possibly shoot okay maybe shoot this out
more I don't know yeah great thank you
for attention right but good layout Yuri
I'd love to kind of see where you take
this next week when we open it up even
more okay let's see Jay Jason Jacobson
okay begin the yang is happening here
right yep thank you mm-hmm and I think
everything's it's an exciting layout
let's not let's not forget that it's a
very exciting that but there's too much
of a symmetry happening as you said yin
yang yes so the other problem I'm having
with this is that this resonate
you see the baselines here yes almost on
the same baseline this is where if you
plan this out a little bit more you can
get it to work but the problem is it
shouldn't be on the baseline because
it's so totally different hmm so you
need to break it
I like that resonate that's the journal
for graphic design Wow Wow just with
just one little movement it's to make
this pace so you make all the pages so
brilliant Chris I mean they are
brilliant
but you make them even more brilliant
thank you and you're repeating a lot of
information I get that and it's just
you're losing space and you do that so
be mindful I know you want more elements
to work with I could see something
working really beautifully here
and see here let me try and grab
something here real quick maybe I'll
grab this one and I'll delete this
because I think yes oh it's this in and
then I were to let's see copy that
okay reduce this down a little bit so
you can see that if you just break the
information up differently like I said
you can create a whole different texture
I'll you know I I'm gonna break it but
you see like these things look very
different than these other things
yeah related this versus this beautiful
and while I did it later because they're
on the same axis same access then
there's similar shapes so if I just
spaced it out maybe I could get it to
work I don't know yeah okay this should
have been like one one thing here it's
just harder to work with when you move
something so I eventually I could make
it work but not the second and I also
wanted to open a space so you can flow
through and maybe the tension would work
better if this were pushed a little bit
more well what if we take the open date
and put it underneath eight so that but
no no no the body copy that you move to
the side which is open uh-huh and bring
it underneath the letter eight somewhere
in that vicinity okay good not now you
got that
push and pull okay okay still broken
still need some more it's just some
ideas mozu coming back mo okay well I
have to point this out this is super not
easy to read like very difficult to read
because low contrast you need to be
mindful of that I'm glad they're trying
that yeah really pushing it there I like
how he is creating a 3d effect using tip
that's why I picked this one but I want
to be able to see it let me lock that
layer back up so you're you're kind of
creating we've seen things like this in
it they're actually really beautiful
when you do it the right way the problem
is we need to skew this type more
there's an effect on this and you want
to see it like where's the skew tool
excuse me this year
I'm gonna tell you messes up guys well
you want a stronger like 90 degree turn
okay so if you're gonna play around with
stuff like this
go all the way because right now it's
kind of like not right yeah okay you
know I'm talking about yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's it's it can be aware of things
that sometimes we play it safe we think
oh let me play it safe but if you're
playing safe then it's not right yeah
you know what I really like this this is
the first time I've seen this
the inclusion the register symbol adds a
whole nother element right because
you're not really allowed to draw any
shapes just yet so using the register
symbol that's pretty ingenious right I
kind of like that and it's it's almost
like this little label a little logo and
it's really cool so being able to find
characters that you might not normally
see and and using them within your
layout
pretty cool applaud you for that okay
sheriff Hadean hmm not afraid I love it
not afraid very very bold it could be
cleaned up a little bit because it's too
everything there's too much tight
letting happening but I love the
direction that
this design is going mmm okay my one
thing is like I feel like there's some
weird rhythm going here something is off
the cadence the flow and maybe you take
this I don't know
nice I let's try a little bit okay
beautiful oh my god Kim breathe okay
Michael Wow let's look at Michael's work
Michael's like just using this kind of
scatter approach and just shooting type
all over the place
it is fairly hard to read for me right
I'm thinking you don't even need this I
know you feel like we tell you guys to
make things bleed like that sometimes
it's not even necessary yeah so enough
of the three down here yeah maybe maybe
you know besides the scattered letters I
think that area where that there's
typography it's very beautiful if we
could zoom in could we admire the beauty
of it please nice nice job I think
there's I love how there's bold and then
light but then it's track that regular
very nice what about here
using a loud open letting open tracking
different a lot of different visual ways
that are happening here yeah but I want
to give kudos for trying it out cuz if
you don't you never know you never know
okay
all right it probably needs something
here I just don't know what that thing
is right maybe needs this that's feeling
a little uncomfortable for me down there
what if we just rotate it mmm folks
don't be afraid of vertical and
horizontal rotation then I think I want
to bring this over to make it related
right there
yes okay Wow poof and last little thing
is let's just shoot it over a little bit
I don't know I did the relationship
between the Z and the are on the N is
almost the same such a triangle with all
sides equal so I would always make it
our socialist
it something okay let's see yeah we
already talked about that one already
talked about that okay this one has some
problems here of a steel Peter Roth whoo
okay I think you took the tight tight
tight thing and you made it super tight
you made it really tight
the problem is we have three or four
different things that aren't talking to
each other the mast-head resonate it's
got its own visual language and then
just like to make it even crazier you
added an outline version here a stroke
and it's just making everything it's
like everything is screaming for
attention like look at me no look at me
no looking yes the problem is okay yes I
did just simplify things if you feel
like something is funky with your layout
just reduce the number of tricks
yes type it's been outlined because I
don't think I have the typeface of this
hill took care of that for me I can't
adjust it as much but it's just so and
then look at the space this yes it's
just weird shapes that are being created
unintentionally yes all right and this
so can I can I give you kudos for trying
all this out so we can come and tell you
guys what not to do yeah thank you I
this is exactly how you learn you get it
try these funky stuff and at the same
time please please make sure that you
implement all the things that we're
telling you so we know that you're
learning because if you're not
implementing it then I'm confused
yes okay Unity's layout I like a lot
she's doing something January February
2018 breaking out the information she's
just taking one basic idea really
driving the contrast really big point
size very black very heavy and bold and
then something a little bit small or in
all caps yeah Harley place barricade
can I give you a quick feedback on this
yoongi your your your talent is just
beyond it's amazing you know what you're
doing if I may push you a little bit
further it's to be aware of scattered
space right now there's a lot of scatter
space and there's
also a safe white margin that is going
almost around the page be aware of these
things I would like to see this layout
one more time or two more times with
some other tweaks and variations and
massages so if you look at this layout
it's got a similar proportion amount of
white as the top as the bottom so do
what we always do here just take it and
push it to the top and then take it and
push it to the bottom and see what
happens see if the layout becomes more
interesting or worse okay and again
which is gonna crop it differently and
show you kind of what is creating all
this tension that's created maybe
georgous yes and then and then remember
with the white space at the top you
don't want it to be dead you want to
make it active by bringing a satellite
in awesome job Chris it needs to be
rotated so they can speak to one another
right sure gorgeous right now it's a
little bit too straight but but you guys
get the idea it's right now it's one
almost 130 so we're just yeah zooming
through everything and we already talked
about this
Jim Wang okay a lot of interesting
things happening here I like and
appreciate the random letter spacing all
caps generally very hard to read but I
actually like what you're doing here and
you smartly kind of decrease the the
letting here it's just like it's
becoming like this rain pattern that
you've created whereas the other layout
we Milka described as seeds growing into
trees this is almost like a canopy like
a weeping willow so like it's hanging an
upside down so there's something really
cool there and you've got a lot of
things going on so this is a question I
forget who asked this it could have been
youjung I don't know ask this but almost
too many things going on right now again
you could just really simplify this okay
just go simplify use one trick and see
what happens instead of throwing every
trick in the book I generally advise you
to stay away from the edges just jammy
things in there yeah if I look at this
and I say okay look how does this make
me feel and I can tink thank you for
doing this I really appreciate it
because you you're showing us
what works and what doesn't work so to
me if I just had this hey I would be
totally fine with that's that's kind of
cool right I don't know it needs
something's too flat and he is aware of
that it's too flat what do you want to
put in there I think I think the problem
is the direction right now this one is
working the top area is working
vertically and then we have something
coming in horizontally so there's a
crash coming in they're not they're not
talking to each other yet what if you
take all that kabadi copy on the left
the all the light beautiful stuff and
then rotate it horizontally okay that
what that works I was thinking of having
the the spine at line with one another
sort of an alignment because you have a
beautiful strong axis with where the
names are right now okay so let's work
on this it's like yes this could be
really cool it just needs to kind of
everything else has to play second
fiddle so to speak there's a star and
the stars on the stage everything else
work with a star
don't try to compete and upstage your
star okay yeah we'll figure it out but
not today you guys be aware of all this
funky space that is created when you
have text coming in this way and text
coming in this way or text coming in
this way you get all this weird space be
aware of that how do you get rid of it
is by rotating things around and having
their backbone speak with one another
does that help
yes okay so let's keep going where I
talk about masterpiece how much I'll pay
for it
if any a sign PDF copy later Ryan Genki
okay it's it's a nice layout I like it
used to breathe good offsetting good
satellite good attention good good
Chuck's position good focal point good
overall right I mean maybe you just need
a yes maybe yes yes
you don't want you want to be aware of
that dead space okay job beautiful
everything together good job good job
good job good job Ryan are you paying
attention I have a quick metaphor here
you know if you're designing a room and
you're you're decorating you're an
interior designer if you have like a
painting that pulls a little bit of a
color from the pillows and the flooring
and the and of Oz's that you've
purchased that brings the whole room
together that's what this thing does
it's adding a little bit of paint a
little texture to the whole space and it
will activate it and bring it all
together for you maybe that's not the
perfect spot for it move on but bonnet
but note I like the big eight really
cool I don't like this little white
thing that's trapped in here and you're
trying lots of different tricks here
with this some somehow I feel like maybe
this is the element that needs to kind
of come back into the play with us maybe
I don't know maybe make it relate I'm
not sure just yet okay it needs
something like that okay wow I can't
believe with just one movement how you
make things come alive you know I can do
that because it's time for us the end
job good job
yeah what are they doing next week Chris
are you gonna talk about no Marc Marc
will tell us later okay I think we're do
you talk about this layout here there
were some problems I really like this
this is very interesting
maybe the position is a little bit funny
yeah I like that you cut off the bottom
so you've got the top very legible
I like the lime in here I think maybe we
just need to push this further south or
something nice understanding of that
spine beautiful genic beautiful yes
or is it Yannick Jana Jana I'm sorry I
don't know I don't wanna say his name
but maybe maybe close up the spacing
because you see I see the white bar see
the white bar there that's cool I like
it because it's the same height as the
Journal of graphic design I like it okay
for me that speaks okay watch this just
cuz I want to challenge Milkha why don't
we just jam it right up to it
please I appreciate you doing this thank
you Chris mm-hmm and if we took this and
took this and just upset a little bit I
don't know maybe I broke it because I
like the tension least these two things
coming and budding up to each other and
it really draws this baseline from the
Journal of graphic design it sheets all
the way down it's a very sharp line
something to think about okay okay the
rest of you guys good job we're just out
of time that's what I did except for
Pilate Pilate come on man look at his
layout what are we doing here all kinds
of weird shapes jamming things in a
corner this is one of those things where
let's let's work on this man I love you
thank you for doing this so we can all
be reminded of what not to do
where we're like you know this prison
bar everywhere this trapped space
everywhere and nothing speaks to one
another so I appreciate you doing that
so we can all learn what not to do
that's a very nice kind of compliment
and a slap at the same time so Nick
Robin this is actually pretty nice
layout
probably tighten up some of the spacing
I think this is like should be here
maybe just really bring this one
the stronger grid like pretend like
that's the line yes I love it maybe just
maybe take this this and this and just
bring it up a little bit I don't need to
be so far away okay and then now we have
new issues with yeah you right with a
dead space so just have to take the
whole thing maybe move them up or down
nice that down a little bit ah some
something okay all right all right you
got the magic touch Chris this is a
really nice layout the journal for
graphic design
probably one of the nicer I like the
introduction is exclamation points yeah
resonate yes because just resonate okay
last lay out last lay out Sarah whoo
Sarah let me look at this I want to make
sure that we at least mention or look at
some of the submissions from women
because there's a majority of our men so
I just want to just do that one
acknowledge all you women that are brave
enough to do play with us I some some
issues here I just don't love the way
that this type creates a triangle I like
a symmetrical beauty and sometimes these
shapes you're working hard to get all
these things lined up you even added
this forward slash in there so just to
kind of really drive that shape but I
just don't know Logan do you like this
Sarah I I like to overall composition
and I understand what Chris is talking
about this is the same example as the
one where we had the criss cross coming
in with the resonant in the middle and
then Chris went in there and just you
know
turkey knit yeah if that's gonna be your
focal point go in there and just have
some fun with it because right now is
just to you know to structure to uptight
it is a laxative oh my god and that's
how I ended so hey everybody thank you
very much for tuning in with us for
another typography Tuesdays I'm Christo
my my co-teacher and in this class has
been milk of Buchan and it's been
wonderful to have you as part of this I
hope you'll be able to join us next week
mocha and we're gonna put your
information how to get in touch with
mocha if you're a big corporation you
need some some help some consulting some
training feel free to reach out to her
include her information below if you
want to reach out to her as a teacher as
a mentor as a friend please send her a
personal message so she knows who the
heck you are cuz she's not one of these
social people online she only talks to
me she knows okay yeah I feel free to
connect me on Instagram and my facebook
public space public Facebook page or
LinkedIn or all information down below
okay
guys they
you very much for sticking out with us
if you made it from the beginning to end
congratulations go out go have yourself
an adult beverage awesome job teen
thanks for tuning in this it we'll see
you guys next week where mark will tell
us what exactly we need to do so next
week we've got multiple weights and
sizes so it opens up the gates any size
any weight and I expect a little bit of
a train wreck so don't disappoint me
everybody okay that's it Jonah get us
out of here peace see you next time okay
thank you
bye everybody bye bye
[Music]